so Pete you got to see the Sega Genesis
mini I did the show floor is probably
opening right now as we're talking if
you're watching this video as it goes
live but yes I get came by and gave me
an early look no way I mean how how did
it play I played really well um you know
like as I'd expect because m2 is behind
the emulation for all of these games m2
is known for doing Sega's Sega Aegis
releases they're really highly renowned
for their emulation yeah and you know if
you look back at what the previous like
third-party licensed Genesis consoles
were from at games
this is far in a way better it is it is
exactly what I'd expect and I play
Genesis almost on a weekly basis at home
with real Hardware you know on vintage
displays on modern displays and this
just felt like you know I was at home
playing a real Genesis game for the most
part could I maybe found something a
nitpick about it I know but I didn't
feel anything weird it just felt good if
I gots playing Genesis cool cool so like
just I mean emulation was top-notch
right and but I guess like so m2 is
known for offering a lot of like cool
like options and extra is there any kind
of that in there not a ton it's not so
much like the Sega ages games or they
actually do give you most of that stuff
I think that's kind of where they're
known for that but you know one of the
yeah there are like filters if you want
like a CRT look but the coolest thing is
the the language is I want to say there
were at least like eight to ten language
options there and I said oh is this just
for the UI or does this impact games as
well he said no no this impacts the
games as women every game can be played
in all of the languages that they gave
you which is like super impressive and a
lot of those include games that never
really came out in the certain
territories they've been translated for
right so Monster World for for example
Mega Man wildly wars I guess that was on
sega channel but mas world 4 is a
perfect example of a game that we did
not get in the West you know we have now
and that series has gotten sort of a
revival right like people have been
buying up those like switched sequels /
remakes and stuff yeah yeah so it's
great to finally be able to play that
game in English and there's even some
stuff on there that was never on the
Genesis like the Darius so Genesis had a
guy or Darius - never had the original
Darius so that games on there it plays
really well the original arcade version
of that was like three monitors wide
yeah this is not that it's fit on a four
by three display but it's still really
cool to be able to do that likewise the
game you might be familiar with known as
Ted
Tetris which doesn't sound that exciting
to say but that game was released on
Genesis in such small quantities I
believe only three cartridges exist the
last one in auction went for 10 grand so
look it's not necessarily oh this is an
amazing game to play on Genesis
specifically but the fact that m2 is
involved the fact that they're going to
links to get games like Tetris as basic
as it is it's still really rare and
obscure but it represents like something
special about the Genesis and they're
treating this as something special as
well and that even shows through in the
hardware the yeah of course the power
switch works in the reset button switch
works but the cartridge flap works as
well
there's nothing that's in there but it
works the little door on the bottom that
you would pull off in the expansion port
to plug in the seat Sega CD that also
works so it's like you really do have
this little mini Genesis and yeah you're
playing with a 3 button controller but I
mean how did it how did that stuff feel
like in terms of the hardware the the
plastic feels a little bit different but
not bad ok you know and maybe that's
because I'm comparing it to controllers
I've been using or have been used for
20-30 years at this point right so what
it really came down to though when I was
playing the game did it react the way I
wanted it to was I able to play the
games the way I intended yes which there
are a lot of third-party controllers
that aren't that but this isn't exactly
a third-party thing this is a sega made
system so in cooperation with them too
and the fact that both teams are taking
it so seriously is is great to see and i
really look forward to playing more
honestly dude that's awesome and that's
the sega genesis mini for more III 2019
news be sure to tune in to GameSpot
[Music]